president biden though says the economy
is looking good but he acknowledged on
friday quote we have a long way to go
this as the white house now says its
student loan forgiveness plan will cost
an estimated
240 billion dollars over the next decade
this week's rollout of the plan has been
rocky getting pushback from both sides
of the aisle the concerns from democrats
come at a somewhat surprising time they
were hoping the program would help them
pick up momentum to keep control of
congress ahead of the november midterms
christina raffini is at the white house
with the latest christina good morning
good morning nancy well the white house
says this is a one-time only deal
designed to help people still recovering
from the financial impact of the
pandemic and although it's popular with
some borrowers the program is not
without controversy
after days of being pressed on the price
tag for president biden's student debt
relief programs
[Music]
the white house now says it estimates
the plan will cost about 24 billion
dollars a year if three quarters of
those eligible enroll why was this
number that we didn't have the past
couple days we had to choose a number
and we felt like 75 was the most
defensible as for why you're getting it
today you guys asked us for it officials
argue the plan is considered paid for
because other administration policies
will help reduce the deficit and we're
using a portion of that a very small
portion of it to provide relief to
middle-class families but critics of the
plan which provides up to ten thousand
dollars in relief for americans making
as much as 125 000 a year argue that
it's unfair and too expensive i think
it's a bad idea
an awful lot of americans choose not to
go to college even some democrats
including congressman chris pappas who's
facing a tough race in new hampshire
this november said the plan doesn't do
enough to address quote the underlying
issue of the affordability of higher
education
the debt relief rollout comes as the
president is shifting into campaign mode
ahead of the midterms we're at a serious
moment in our nation's history
the maga republicans don't just threaten
our personal rights and economic
security
they're a threat to our very democracy
unveiling harsher language and more
targeted attacks at a dnc rally in
maryland this week the maga republicans
win control of the congress
it won't matter where you live
women won't have the right to choose
anywhere
maggot republicans don't have a clue
about the power of women
let me tell you something
they are about to find out
now democrats know that kind of language
appeals to their base and they're hoping
measures like this student loan debt
relief as well as efforts to protect
abortion rights are going to get their
voters to turn out at the polls in just
73 days jeff
christina thank you